the players it will take a while to get
used to duda looks pretty chilled i
gotta say but uh either way uh for the
other players maybe the younger players
it's gonna be completely new and uh yeah
maybe this is the future
definitely and uh we do see they have
headsets on obviously to shut out any
kind of sound
but they can also listen to music right
yeah and this is going to be exciting as
well because a lot of the players
especially the ones who didn't play in
the tour final in oslo yeah last year
they won't be used to this kind of novel
experience of putting their headphones
on and listening to their favorite tunes
yeah and then we see actually magnus
carson choosing his music right now wow
and i see that it's a list called
david's greatest hits challenge for
those of you who have been following the
tour last season i did try and slip in
some song titles to the commentary and
magnus is listening to some of those
songs oh that's cool and here we go you
guys the oslo esports cup the first
major in the 2022 season has started and
david what's happening on the board it's
a sicilian defense skyer and uh that
means it's gonna be dynamic from the
start it's gonna be a lot of action in
this one uh duda opening with his king's
pawn magnus replying with a sicilian and
i'm expecting him to trade a set of
pawns in the center now there we go
capture and
this is called the khan variation it's
black just allowing white to take center
but black is going to set up a wall of
pawns it's going to heat up as the game
goes on yeah i've never seen magnus play
this variation with the black pieces
actually i mean he's he's played the
shreznikov famously in the world
championships um and he doesn't normally
go c5 unless he does the stretchnet off
so i think this is going to be uh
well we're going gonna we've seen
something new uh this can variation
where you get double edged positions so
good exciting start yeah already do the
thinking it's only move five but i
expect this to continue actually for the
next few moves as both sides kind of
decide what's set up to choose where to
put their pieces where to put their
pawns
and uh yeah magnus you're right there
simon with this choice of opening he
showed he's not scared he wants a
full-blooded fight even with black and
uh yeah i'm excited already about the
choice of opening by both players that
we see duda just taking a few moments
and eventually deciding to bring his
bishop out one of the main moves
and uh okay the moves speeding up black
development bishop kicking white's
knight back and now parking his bishop
on a nice long diagonal yeah and uh i
have to say i'm very excited to see this
uh variation actually on the board
because
this uh bishop retreat is quite
ambitious but it does also have its
risks and the primarily one the primary
one sorry is the the fact that some
pawns are left undefended on the right
side but duda doesn't actually go for
that instead
just uh moves his queen one square
forward yeah and now black needs to
catch up with peace development black's
pieces are very much asleep at the
moment so maybe bringing out one of the
two black knights maybe pushing a pawn
in the center first for black okay he
does bring out a piece
at some point white will castle most
likely on the king side often in the
sicilian we can see white decide which
side to castle on and his intentions if
they're really ambitious he'll castle on
the long side but first he offers a
trade of dark squared bishop so duda may
be surprised by magnus's opening choice
just taking a positional approach on
this last move
and uh magnus he'll still have some
issues to solve once these dark squared
bishops get traded off
uh where to put the black king we might
well see an attack later on a mutual
attack it's very ambitious i think from
magnus to play like this to come out of
a new opening a sharp opening and i'm
i'm hoping uh that dude is going to
castle queenside here i'd love to see uh
queenside castling i mean the sicilian
the opening they're playing here is is
known to be one of the most interesting
openings you can get very dynamic play
where white gets his pieces out quickly
and attacking on both sides of the board
so this is this is a great start um
exciting start yeah i know if i was
facing you here simon i wouldn't even
have to guess which side the white king
is going it's definitely going that way
and uh if we do see the kings parked on
opposite sides of the board as you
mentioned it's just going to be complete
chaos both sides throwing pawns against
each other's kings first magnus carson
just takes a step forward with one pawn
just solidifying the dark squares but a
bit slow it's a little bit slow but
magnus has actually played this
variation before and the thing is though
it's not a favorite of his he's only
played it five times in his career and
they were never any serious games
they're always like a super fast chess
and he's actually following a game that
he played against hikaru nakamura in a
blitz tournament um
in 2020 and there he lost and he
actually lost and get this 23 moves oh
so
wow what can this mean has he found he
has to have funding in this position
because uh the great the great thing
about magnus is he has like a
photographic memory when it comes to
remembering and recalling his own games
so there must be something here down the
line that he's thought about oh and
simon you're going to be happy with this
last move white knight has just
developed itself but that has cleared
the path for the white king to castle on
the queenside on the long side and okay
moment of truth which side is that white
king going if dude castle's left with
the king he's going on the attack he
wants to win and maybe we'll see a
situation where magnus is under pressure
and uh facing a big attack very quickly
if duda castle's on the right side of
the board though it will become a slower
game yeah i've been looking at these
positions uh quite a lot recently so i
just finished the chess ball course uh
on mikael tao's best games which is just
out now and uh um if you want to learn
this open sicilian uh the legend they're
calling the magician tao he loved these
positions as white he would he would win
nearly every time just by playing the
most aggressive setup and he'd always
put his king on the queen side and he'd
start pushing uh those pawns on the
other side of the ball which is called a
pawn storm and you try to try to storm
the position with your pawns so uh i'd
love to see i'd love to see something
like that happen here a bit of a bit of
a pawn storm so yeah but it's going to
be an interesting moment here because um
if he chooses to go like you say to the
left with the king you know all out war
then uh okay we're going to see that
duda is in a really aggressive mood but
if he just decides to kind of move the
king to the right then we're going to
actually see that okay dude is like well
i'm just going to take a very
strategical approach i'm going to start
targeting um there's one pawn that
doesn't have any natural defenders and
that is the
pawn
two squares in front of the black queen
and you're going to see doodle pile up
all the pressure on that point yep so
this is the pawn you mean now yeah here
ivanka and if dude does indeed make the
move we want to see the move we're
expecting and castle on the long side
then the rook is primed and ready to
attack this pawn later on it's a
backward pawn it can't really move
forward later without just getting
captured so it is a long-term target and
simon pointed out this is the other idea
to just throw pawns forward on the other
side white king is super safe note that
it's not just got three points in front
of it but it also has two perfect
defenders i think white's king is super
safe on this side and why not
uh get just a ready-made attack if you
can for example if black does castle the
attack begins and white is clearly ahead
in this race throwing pawns towards the
black king
the other option i think he'll regret it
if he takes it castling on this side of
the board for white
i don't see how this is really going to
turn into anything special for white now
king's on the same side of the world
it's impossible to really attack safely
at least and okay he's delayed the
decision simon are you happy to see this
one f for forward the f pawn has marched
forward maybe preempting the march of
the g pawn as well
yeah i'm quite kind of happy to see that
one i mean i would have been more
excited if he'd you know put his king on
the left-hand side
but this is a logical and aggressive
move he's using those pawns to try and
uh create some chaos uh i mean i was
thinking if i could get any position as
white against magnus carson this one
would be my position because
he's obviously brilliant at every part
of the game but i think the one way uh
you can try to beat magnus is to come at
him and throw everything at him
positionally he's incredibly hard to
break down so um so you know this is
going to be very exciting but i'm
wondering what will happen after this
magnus probably has to castle king side
at some point it looks really scary to
me um and uh maybe break with you know
one of these pawn pushes which is
typical in the position that black can
also do yeah it's all about these
central pawns and uh it depends whether
white can now get his pawns racing
rolling towards the black king in time
or whether now because white has delayed
uh castling his own king whether black
is in time for example if the pawn does
much forward to just challenge in the
center and now it does open up and if
things do open up white's king will wish
it had committed itself earlier so okay
another critical moment will magnus uh
sorry in this position will he castle
his king or will he use the duda
technique and delay the decision himself
uh other options would be maybe for
black to start pushing pawns just hoping
that the white king ends up on that side
of the board let's go back to the
players it's uh it's kind of a game of
cat and mouse right now
neither side really
showing their intentions but both sides
clearly uh hoping or expecting the game
to liven up at some point cool
young christophe duda coming all the way
from poland to play in the oslo esports
cup and he is uh
well he's been on fire lately and he's
qualified for the candidates and he made
it all the way to the final
and the charity cup i have to say he
really has figured out this format
online rapid chess yeah last season on
the tour he had some good events well
some decent events uh but some quite
poor events and uh now he seems much
more consistent also he's the only
player in this field who is in the
candidates tournament in the summer in
just under two months now so uh we
actually had him on our podcast and he
he was saying he's going to be hiding
some opening preparation he can't play
his best openings because his rivals in
the candidates tournament in this summer
they will be watching all of these games
and they'll be studying them really
closely
so maybe that will affect duda's play
slightly but then again he's quite
universal he plays a lot of different
openings especially with white
and uh yeah the same goes for magnus
carson so um i think both players will
just be happy to push the battle into
the middle game so that they don't
reveal any uh secrets and what i liked
yesterday during the opening ceremony is
that uh when you asked judo whether he
was feeling confident he said absolutely
yeah
yeah 100 you know he's confident and
it makes for an exciting battle when you
have players who believe in themselves
and believe in their abilities because
if you're going to beat magnus you can't
be second guessing yourself
and uh okay magnus decides not to commit
his king and instead concentrate on
developing the light squad bishop and
now it's got a hole to escape too
yeah maybe pushing those pawns towards
the white knights as well to destabilize
them and uh push the white knights to
worse squares if that pawn advances one
more square forward
maybe a bit of a decision for duda to
make so
um yeah the evaluation bar above the
players the orange bar we see there it
likes white it says that white has a
plus one advantage a one pawn advantage
but
let's ignore it for now uh i think this
one is very much about how the next few
moves go if white can continue the
attack yes it's going to be great for
him but it's not easy to do that
yeah i think
he's got to make a decision now where he
puts the king it's one of those things
you kind of you can delay and delay but
the more you delay a decision like this
it kind of like you overthink it you
either go queenside you go for it or you
go kingside a slightly safer uh way to
proceed so it's gonna be very
interesting but i'm actually quite
transfixed by the psychedelic wallpaper
as well i'm sort of looking at that and
i'm like well you know this is pretty
impressive isn't it the whole whole
arena
and this is a first where you've got
everyone there um just opposite each
other in this proper e-gaming
environment so it's it's yeah it's nice
to see something new i've heard like
discussions about and i'm here to hear
from you guys do you think chess online
chess of course is an esport does it
qualify for being an esport
yeah why not yeah yeah it's definitely
if it's fast it's furious you mean you
see
i mean
more excitement on the board uh
especially in online chess especially in
rapid chess than a lot of other uh
esports a lot of other games so yeah and
if you think how many people are
actually playing online now yeah just
around the world it it's an incredibly
high number so you know it's it's one of
the most popular games online so it must
be an esport yeah that's where everyone
plays now online and if you think about
it like all the other esports usually
like some some war gaming kind of games
they're kind of based on chess right
chess is the original
battle game and you know the ultimate
battle game basically right yeah
definitely you know because there's two
players testing their wits against each
other they have to come up with the
strategies they have to position their
their forces in the best way they have
to out-think the other person because
they're you know all the information is
on the board and uh i mean the beauty of
online chess is that you know with other
computer games you know you know you
need a super powerful pc with the
massive graphic card or whatever my
technology
yeah you know and uh with chess you can
just play on your phone i mean
this is one thing that i've seen
throughout norway
uh it's norway is jack chess obsessed
and you know i'll be on the bus and i'll
be seeing people playing online chess
and i see young people play i see old
people women men everyone exactly doing
it and so quite rightfully so it is an
esports and uh i i love the background
myself going back to that subject you
know it's exciting yeah and it's
something that you know it's kind of
taking chess to that extra level yeah
can i ask what music you play because
i'd have to put like some pink floyd on
or something
with that background i think we all
should like i agree
i think some okay this is again showing
my age by simon my uh some kind of like
trance kind of like
and oh after a long pause we do have a
move yeah and
duda continues to procrastinate he
hasn't chosen which side to put his king
on and
like simon said you can't delay it too
much longer with white soon the position
will open up or soon black will be fully
ready uh to kind of create some threats
and the longer white's king sits in the
center the longer he delays the decision
i think uh he's just gonna miss his
chance so this is one thing i'm kind of
really bad at a sin that i commit all
the time not committing just kind of
delaying delaying delaying but there
will come a moment when you will regret
not choosing one plan you just have to
choose a plan and stick to it duda is
not doing that he pushes a pawn to stop
the advance of black's pawns but that
last white move it's very slow it
doesn't really help his position uh in
the grand scheme of things yeah i was
going to ask actually is this a sign
that duda is maybe lacking in
confidence
because you know like i'm looking at my
database of course i have the
information here so it's easy for me to
say but you know why it traditionally
takes a decision with a king you know
either goes to the right to the left but
you know those are the main moves this
move i only played once before in a
junior tournament i think it's just that
it's the first game of the tournament
the first game of the day and duda just
wasn't really warmed up enough to go
straight for the attack straight for the
kill maybe playing the world champion he
thought okay let's just grow into the
game and get in the flow a bit later on
but sometimes early days you still have
to attack you still have to go for it
and magnus now has blocked up the center
what do we think of this move
uh he's trying to open things up maybe
or trying to at least stop the advance
of white's pawns but quite committal
itself yeah it seems like a quite a
standard idea uh often white wants to
push the freddie pawn which is attacked
now one square forwards and when you're
playing these positions when you're
playing any opening
i think it's so important to know what
pawn breaks you have and if white does
push that pawn i mean maybe we can show
it uh black can react in the center with
this with this very typical uh break
with the the backwards pawn uh even so
this is sort of uh
pawn goes here and now black at some
point i don't know even now can push
this one forward so this is like a
typical plan from black you know moving
forwards playing this counter attack in
opening the sicilian and taking chances
when he gets uh the opportunity yeah
really exploding open position now and
uh your right side and it's not clear
whose king is going to be safer still
both of them parked in the middle of the
board uh when the lines do begin to open
so dude would love to play this move as
you mentioned push this pawn forward
this is kind of a really typical really
thematic
way to start an attack you block things
up and then you push your pawns now that
the center is closed but
magnus for sure will explode the
position open uh with his own pawn push
so dude really has to be careful of uh
pushing forward while his king's in the
middle but now the issue is maybe you've
missed your chance you've missed your
shot if you castle queenside now which
looks desirable the king's still pretty
safe then suddenly black can create a
direct threat back and even win material
by bringing his bishop out this wasn't
available before this bishop was blocked
in but now suddenly look at this it's a
skewer attacking the queen attacking the
rook behind it and uh when the queen
moves black simply wins material black
will pick off the white rook so suddenly
dude
he may be regret uh will be regretting
not taking that opportunity to get his
king to this side going the other side
as well does have drawbacks you go into
the eyeline of this black bishop still
black can gain time attacking the white
queen the momentum is potentially
changing um the evaluation bar is still
not too impressed by what magnus has
done but for a human it looks like a
very very sensible move also note this
piece locked in so strategically as well
black very happy to block the center and
make this bishop a bit of a useless
piece for now
just looking at its own pawns can i just
add one thing um this kind of pawn
central break that black has just done
also works because the white knight uh
sitting on the b3 square is kind of out
of the game if it were in the center
don't be careful about pushing that pawn
to attack it yeah even if the knight
were on the other side of the board if
you could kind of pick up this knight
and put it on this square or this square
then it would be really dangerous black
is just weak in those squares but okay
dude after another long think does to
decide to trade bishops and
after black recaptures this rook
actually on a decent square can swing
across now uh white has blocked things
up so this is the key moment can
black break open the center or does he
have to wait and prepare that for a move
or two i think i think it's so important
when you look at these openings um
to there's a couple of things we
mentioned pawn pushers but you've got to
think about tempo and timing if you're
going to this sharp open sicilian
probably one of the sharpest openings
you can get
the tempo increases so you don't really
have time to play like a3 uh the move
that dude played generally i mean it's
probably not a terrible move but you
want to play with a bit more urgency and
when you're playing openings just having
that in the back of your mind how urgent
are the moves and the ideas a3 seems
slow it might give the advantage away
it's just it's a good thing to to bear
in mind and magnus has moved there
throwing the knight straight into the
center of the board very interesting
move it's very interesting but it's kind
of a little bit unlike magnus in a way
because it's quite committal move
because you know if the knights get
traded off black has compromised the
pawn structure for all time
and uh
i i kind of expected magnus to actually
build a little bit more yeah i think it
was just not much else choice uh not
much else to do if black had castled
kingside in this position then suddenly
white will start to unleash the pawns
push them forward so i think he's just
trying to counter counter against this
and by trading pieces remember black is
still a bit cramped this bishop in
particular can't develop itself to a
good square while you're cramped you
want to trade pieces and want to swap
things off and now some crazy stuff is
happening on the board could be a
valuation bar i mean is that is that
yeah okay let's catch up with a position
this knight was attacking the queen we
saw a trade and here duda has instead of
moving his knight which was under fire
just moved his queen to the side eyeing
up the rook on long this diagonal but
can magnus just grab this knight
maybe you can just give away your rook
here and after you take this pawn
threatening the rook threatening to
promote maybe there's some
counter-attack maybe a queen check maybe
the white king suddenly is in big danger
in the middle of the board it's
really committal he played it so quick
didn't he i mean this is the position
where you're going to play a move such
as this you take your time it's a
critical moment and he he shuffled that
queen over and probably not having
enough time to calculate so it's uh he
just assumed you know that you can't
capture the knights we know what they
say about assumption so yeah
i don't know
assumption is the mother of all um
that's what i know i thought you were
gonna say the other one
uh that's the only one and i think i
think it's from snatch or one of those
films
so don't assume don't assume okay
so yeah big big moment now magnus if he
doesn't take this white knight then
black's pawn in the center of the board
might just fall off white's queen is
attacking that black pawn in the center
and black does have double pawns on the
d line if you look at the default those
two pawns are very weak if magnus
doesn't take this one move this one
opportunity
to take the white knight to sacrifice
material then well okay magnus has done
it we see the moose very quickly magnus
has sacrificed a rook for a knight so
black is down on material now but look
at that black pawn it's attacking the
rook in the corner wants to make a new
queen and no matter where white's rook
runs away to now black's queen is gonna
jump forward it's gonna pounce check the
white king black's king at some point is
just gonna castle and white king is
going to be eternally
in danger so you might better play check
and grab the other you know grab that
pawn of whites which we can see but this
is kind of typical for a sicilian when
it goes wrong for white the reason that
people played it's opening the ceiling
as black is the counter attacking
possibilities you get many chances to
suddenly do some counter blow
and magnus is just unleashing here um
this you know even if black simply
castles which he has done the rook can
come to the middle white's king is stuck
in in this bad position and uh black has
has great attacking possibilities here
i'd say yeah still anything can happen
so black is behind on material if his
attack doesn't work then white has an
extra rook for a night and will most
likely win but if black's attack crashes
through it's going to be awesome why
does the bar just jump down that that
was a strange last move because he's
giving that very strong pawn away he
could have he could have guarded that
pawn the the very advanced black pawn
there instead he's just giving it away i
think he wants to
uh
i mean yeah i agree with you i perhaps
would have grabbed a pawn or maybe
protected that pawn but uh you know
magnus is magnus and he likes to use all
his pieces
use the rook use the bishop yeah maybe
we can just jump in to show what magnus
could have done maybe even stronger in
this last position uh it's all about
this pawn as you said simon this pawn
under fire and firstly you could take
this pawn but this would allow white's
queen to get back into the game and
retreat also ganging up on this pawn
picking it off next move but i think
magnus the move he didn't consider was
just a quiet move bringing his queen in
and uh this would have prevented dude's
last move re-centralizing the white
queen and suddenly at this pawn he's
going to win the game long term magnus
let this ball disappear he let it go he
castled instead and now after the white
queen retreated yes black gets his rook
to the open file hitting the white king
indirectly but this pawn is now doomed
and once this pawn disappears magnus is
banking fully on the attack it's he's
just gambling going all in on an attack
against the white king and look at this
dude he didn't castle with his king he
couldn't he wasn't allowed to so now
he's brought his rook across and his
idea is to castle by hand as we call it
dropping his king back and then
shuffling it off into the corner so it's
long-winded but it's necessary and
magnus needs to strike now otherwise
duda will be
in charge in this game okay are you
still liking it for magnus because the
bar is still over to his side still
looks pretty good to be honest you do
have two or three moves while this king
runs away to safety to create threats so
you could maybe start ganging up on this
central pawn uh in conjunction with the
knight and the rook as well both eyeing
up that pawn you can take this guy at
any moment i don't think magnus is in
trouble yet but he needs to be accurate
now i think maybe he just rushed his
last couple of moves and his advantage
could have been even bigger okay maybe
you could take the other pawn as well
with a bish bishop um
some possibilities uh using that one
even more simple so bishop takes pawn
yeah and uh white can't recapture okay
because of this pin
well and he definitely has more time on
the clock magnus he's played fast young
christophe duda has spent a lot more
time he has less than five
minutes left on the clock in this very
first game in the oslo esports cup now
remember the players they play
matches so magnus and young christoph
will face each other in four rapid games
today best out of those four rapid games
if they are tied after those four games
they will head straight to tie brace
with blitz and armageddon and of course
same situation in all the three other
matches going on right now and the bars
in all games they have been shifting a
little bit from side to side i saw it
was looking very good for jordan from
forest at some point in his first game
against pragnanda but the bar is uh
roughly in the middle in that game right
now and same situation
in all the other
first games as well but for magnus
crossing
it's looking quite good that's what
david is saying
yep but uh
there's a big if yeah at the end of that
so it looks good if magnus is able to
get active and maybe win a few pawns or
get towards that white king that's what
magnus is thinking on now and he's
investing time wisely he needs to stop
at this moment and calculate i'm
expecting the move you mentioned there
simon the black bishop jumping out
taking a pawn
it's just irresistible right if you can
see a porn and you can just take it why
not but uh at the same time duda is two
moves away from getting his king to
safety and then he'll feel confident
that the white rooks will start to play
a big role so
i think both players have hope for the
future
yeah i have to say one thing though you
know once uh simon's move gets played
it's not that easy for black to actually
generate even more counter play and once
the white king puts on his hat and says
right i'm off i'm out of here
yeah there is that potential you know
for things to go seriously wrong because
if two rooks get active
find some lines and the position has a
lot of open lines
then uh it could be trouble for magnus a
bit surprised i know it's the first game
and i think that's showing because their
time handling is peculiar to me because
you know magnus is now having a big
think but he missed the move that david
pointed out it's very strong
infiltration with the queen and uh you
know it's it's hard to adjust to
different time controls like you're
playing uh maybe you've been playing
bullet chess you come here you've got an
extra 14 minutes and you've got to use
it so i think that's something all the
players need to sort of get used to a
bit more uh just adjusting to the new
time control we did see magnus make a
bit of a face there yeah he grimaced he
was not happy with uh how things have
gone or not happy with this position
he's still doing okay but i think maybe
he's starting to realize uh there was
something even better and like simon
says if he'd spent his time just two
moves ago he would have probably won
already but spending his time now didn't
necessarily help too much so the move we
showed was played black bishop came out
took a pawn that was possible because of
a pin and now white's king is run away
so now black's bishop is under fire from
that white pawn in the center of the
board but how naked is that white king
though i mean it is
it's dangerous for young christopher
right now it is but if it gets one more
move maybe it shuffles off to the corner
it's got two pawns uh as clothes to
protect it and to kind of please oh
that's a nice image maybe queen d2 move
the queen in here is something like this
is because you're not actually
threatening to take the bishop here
that's a really nice point something
along that so white isn't actually
threatening to take the bishop is
strange because that b pawn is still
incredibly strong and that might be the
reason the valuation bar is still uh
much in magnus's favor so we have to
show this as simon mentions you can just
make a move so your move is good there
simon bringing maybe the queen into the
game but for example if you just wait if
we just make a move to create some
squares for the black king so you don't
get checkmated later white is not
actually threatening this bishop i miss
this one because after rook takes rook
we see a trade white is actually a whole
rook up here but you can just capture
this rook you can even give away your
queen for the rook
white is a queen up now but remember
this pawn it's still on the board and
black at the end can make a new queen
black actually at the end of this is one
pawn up as well so black would be
winning this position
so if pawn takes bishop isn't
necessarily a threat then black does
have this one move uh maybe instead of
this one maybe there's something more
useful for example you could even push
this pawn forward in the center
just hoping that white captures your
bishop and then the same kind of
mechanism mechanism
uh trading rooks and then giving up your
queen and making a new queen so yeah
lots to consider for magnus carlsen i'm
expecting him as you mentioned there
simon to actually leave his bishop on
the square now yeah i mean i was
thinking queen d2 because you have the
threat of also taking the pawn in the
centre of the board you maybe have a a
check to towards the black king the
white king even you're bringing the
queen nearer to to to that piece
but d5 looks incredibly natural as well
but this is a critical moment he is
using his time better now so i i think
you know the both players are adjusting
a bit more to the to the new environment
you've got to adjust to the environment
you're playing in i know steve whenever
you play uh you often turn up to the
board um like at the last moment should
we say um
is that because you're just trying to
get in the right zone and i think some
people turn up early because they want
to get in the zone by sort of meditating
in some respects but it's
actually the first few times it happened
when i started arriving late to games
was simply because i was disorganized
but uh as time went on i realized that
actually i felt much more comfortable
that way it meant that i could avoid
talking to people
not that i'm trying to be antisocial but
i just try to stay in the zone not get
distracted
and also i just i kind of appreciate
having that extra minute or two just to
kind of psych myself up everyone's at
the board they're doing their thing but
i'm still in my own little world and
um in a way that helps me i know magnus
does the same he's always kind of
if not late then at the last minute and
um yeah just each player has their own
different routine right yeah no i i've
uh
just like you and magnus i saw gary
kasparov would always turn up 10 minutes
late
because he wanted to avoid photograph
the photographers and also people
chit-chatting and having to sign things
which would get them out of the zone
other players i mean i've seen them
arrive like half an hour early and just
sit at the board and make it clear and
actually magnus retreats the bishop
maybe he didn't spot this opportunity or
maybe he just thought well
we'll need to move at some stage if i
can spot it he can spot it so it's just
like i mean he i guess he just went for
the safe option right um but
and that's very safe his bishop's on a
decent square i i guess it's like you
said simon he saw that the bishop wasn't
attacked but he couldn't find anything
useful to do maybe he was unsure about
bringing the black queen in now he has
gone and grabbed a pawn but there we go
the evaluation bar now on white side and
this is what we were warning about yes
black had an attack for a while white's
king was feeling really unsafe but
suddenly if we do that count white has
an extra rook black only has a knight
and a pawn in return
or knight in two points now but one of
the pawns will drop off and yeah i'd be
very tempted to swipe the queen's off
here i mean you know it does seem that
white's king is a little bit more on
secure here so white now if he wants to
can go queen to to to the left to to
force the exchange of queens which in
general i feel would be something white
wants to do he's he's not going to be in
any immediate danger then he has two
rooks two rooks incredibly good uh later
on okay but he's threatening to win the
queen instead yeah right wow bit of a
strange move there but white does have a
threat of bringing his rook in the
middle of the board all the way across
and trapping the black queen and
meanwhile we see pregnant on the brink
of a win potentially what happened in
that game i've heard rumors jordan fun
forest have been super frustrated the
bar was all the way over to the side a
few minutes ago but something must have
happened if it is a blunder i don't know
but the bar all the way over to
pragnanda's side the 16 year old could
be the first player
in this tournament to get a win
yeah and yeah okay it's like they say
you know it's not easy to win those one
games especially if it's complicated or
messy
and uh whilst they can see a pragnanda
and someone who will be happy actually
is rahul who earlier on tweeted that
they were super excited to see the oslo
esports and they were cheering for
pragnando
and there you can see
magnus has actually just retreated his
queen and uh we can see mama jaroff in
full focus mode
he is facing liam leia on the very first
day here in his match we are paying
attention to this game young christoph
judah magnus crossing the bar has been
over to magnus's side but it has shifted
sides
is it now looking good for young
kristoff it's looking good he needs to
find a move here which i think is pretty
obvious it was set up by his previous
move white's rook in the middle of the
board just needs to swing the whole way
across attack the black queen force it
back and then the white rooks can
actually start grabbing pawns i mean you
could take the pawn immediately here as
well couldn't he done the you know yeah
maybe as well maybe another option but
it's certainly looking like this is the
best position white's had right so far
uh he was in trouble he's got rid of
magnus's very dangerous pawn that was
coming down the board and uh yeah i mean
i if i was if i was black here i'd be
you know really upset with uh letting
letting the position slip
yeah it's just offside right now but you
can't be upset this is one thing
when you play chess you have to be
unemotional oh i can't do that i can't i
can't either i think i think yeah some
people have i mean i remember actually
when i played your british championships
and i was so annoyed with myself
yeah i stormed off i did
yeah i i i i i did a bit of a stormer
you know so i don't think i knocked the
pieces over no no no you bet you threw
the score sheet uh
there you see queen takes porn and it's
it's very very natural you know you have
so much emotions
especially when it's built up and if
you've been winning and you let it slip
it's the worst kind of feeling because
you've done this all to yourself and if
you had you know your mind is always
thinking about regrets you know you're
thinking well you know if i just taking
care why did i allow that queen into the
middle of the board
so i was thinking the best thing i ever
saw was someone with a score sheet at
the end of the game he was really upset
and he just made a paper airplane and he
just threw it at his opponent
that is such a good way to
show your depression just make a little
paper airplane and
write in your opponent yeah that must be
a good feeling though but no not
possible to make paper airplanes in uh
the meltwater champions chest or this is
online chess and a few moves on the
board what's happening david yeah things
are heating up on the board and also the
clock look at this both players now
around the two-minute mark and uh as
simon pointed out white's queen went and
grabbed a pawn now it is a rook for a
knight in a pawn that's the material
balance so white ahead on material but
this black knight may be creating some
threats at the very minimum black's
knight is going to go back to the e5
square and plant itself on a nice
outpost magnus carlson he loves kind of
having strategic long-term compensation
he doesn't mind being points down
material down uh he just wants good
pieces and that black knight is going to
be a good piece and there we see duda's
board duda has his board really big on
that huge screen magnus had it much
smaller that's really interesting uh for
me but uh okay here we go i think we
will see some tactics now that duda is
down to one and a half minutes and it's
also a kind of position where
jan kristoff can actually get a bit
nervy because yes that night is uh as
david says heading towards the center
but it's also pointing towards the white
king if you can imagine the black queen
joining
you know in kind of coordinating
together then it's kind of looking a
little bit scary and
you always have to
think about you know
the psychological effects of these type
of moves you know because duda will not
just be visualizing concrete lines he
will be thinking ahead and thinking oh
my god goodness me what's going to
happen if my king gets under a fire from
the queen the rook it's a bit exposed
what can i do and he'll be looking at
keeping control and he has under a
minute on the clock he needs to speed up
this position is getting critical 40
seconds i didn't realize he was so low
40 seconds wow okay minimum just push
your pawn kick that knight out of your
heart for the board there we go that's
the most obvious move you're only next
door he probably hurt you
no no no we can guarantee there is a
sound proof
can not hear us god take take the night
magnus queen takes knight
my point is that that was the most
obvious move but it cost him most of his
remaining time and now duda is going to
be eternally in time trouble down to 40
seconds
yes he's helped that black knight back
to the center of the board but it was
more important to kick it away
especially low on time you don't want a
knight parked in front of you in your
face near your king and uh okay he has
kicked back that black knight and now
the white queen has stepped back black's
queen
needs to jump in i was about to say i'm
in before it's too late queen was almost
trapped very interesting now extremely
interesting i mean as you vancouver
point out the white king is a little bit
exposed uh but duder has control the
center of the board here uh the timing
i've never seen duda lose on time he
seems to handle that short time like
yourself incredibly well david i mean
you live you live on the increment i
mean it's uh
but i mean i got it with 10 seconds on
my clock then uh with uh two hours on my
clock so um duda i will say one thing
about him as well he's one of the best
in the world at material imbalances so
when it gets really crazy when it's a
queen for a few pieces or when it's uh
just a really wild position strange pawn
structures he's really really good there
and magnus normally likes a bit more
control here he's got a knight on a
great square for black but apart from
that uh maybe magnus wants to start
pushing some pawns he just wants to kind
of solidify everything it's not easy
though will we see a check from the
black queen will we see just a waiting
move because that black knight isn't
really under threat if white's
rook takes that black knight in the next
move black's queen can actually just
drop back on the diagonal and check the
white king but no solidity is magnus's
middle name and he's just solidified
that black knight and a queen trait
offered this is a good uh strategy from
judah you know when your king is even in
the slightest bit of danger try and
trade off queens uh the queen is the
most
aggressive piece on the board get her
off yeah and uh i think magnus say
no i think you'll say no you know
because especially when you take into
account the clock situation as well
under a minute more chances to go wrong
if the queens are on the board even if
it does mean retreating the queen back
to where she came from yeah if you trade
the queens now then black is maximum
playing for a draw and that's not
magnus's style he maybe he can hold that
one black's knight is super strong after
all but trading the queens means it's
going to be very one-sided the white
rooks will eventually come into the
element so maybe that black queen has to
go in the direction it came from back on
that diagonal preserve itself what is
magnus thinking about there we go he
does eventually retreat his queen and
duda continues to centralize his pieces
as well
yeah i mean magnus's knight is such a
beast of
a beast of a piece there in the middle
of the board it's supported by the pawn
it's a beautiful beautiful uh you know
you know in a position beautiful
position and the bishops come around as
well but still still just all the
playful here i think it's uh it could go
any result as possible right yeah
computer says 0.0 but definitely if uh
if black loses control white will win
with this extra material if white loses
control maybe that black knight will uh
decide the game so is that what you call
an octo night yevanka that night with
its
controlling eight squares with its
tentacles i i also like simon's
description the beast um yeah now uh
magnus
oh moving the night i mean we were
waxing lyrical about this night yeah
dude his eyes when he made that move
dude his eyes just widened like why has
he moved his great knight to be traded
off that's very strange i mean why the
the knight can never be
budged from the center of the ball
because it couldn't have been attacked
by a white pawn
and he's he's just moved it there i mean
even the rook going up one square now it
is only going to help white's position
very strange just take that just take it
off take it off the board move the king
onto a dark square protecting the rook
as long as you've got that covered 15
seconds for yeah 16 seconds oh he
doesn't take that black knight this is a
really strange move by dude he could
have kept things super simple he's
attacking the black queen though yeah
but it's encouraging the queen to come
forward yeah
some stuff to calculate there i'm not
sure yeah oh maybe the black queen can
jump back into the position maybe the
black queen just has to retreat either
way next move duda will be itching to
get rid of that black knight
he's gone in so now if the queen's come
okay this is a clever check because
magnus needs to keep the queens on uh
otherwise he's going to really really
struggle here couldn't have even traded
the queens actually because there would
have been
as missions as we call it in between
with bishops trading themselves off and
uh okay
now duda he has a one-track mind he's
going to try and trade pieces because
his rook long term is going to be better
than black's bishop yeah that being said
the white king is still slightly open so
yeah magnus on the defensive for sure
yeah i mean if white can get the queens
off the board white's going to win this
game
without a shadow or doubt so black has
to try and uh you know keep the queen
somehow active uh one problem i think
that magnus might have here though is
his bishop i mean as you say he gave up
his beautiful knight but what is that
bishop actually doing okay it's not a
terrible piece but it's not really
attacking anything of whites it's not
aimed at any of white's pieces you you
kind of
to mim to my eyes it doesn't look like a
great piece
well queens and knights combine far
better than queens and bishops as well
so very very strange by magnus there i
agree with you both there but i mean i
i'm not that pessimistic about magnus's
position just because you know the white
king is so shaky if white tries to get
even
you know even a little bit ambitious
you can't do it yeah you can't use both
the rook and the queen because there's
danger of perpetual check i guess white
has to try to play eat this pawn break
in the center and open up the rook uh
that's that's something i'd be trying to
do if i was white here um but you're
mean okay this is a good move from
magnus stopping those opportunities uh
okay he's going for another idea here
trying to try to swap the queens off in
a crafty crafty little check uh over
towards the black king yep if white can
retreat the queen now back to the f5
square next to the black queen swap it
off then white is going to win the rook
will beat the bishop but magnus can
maybe just use his queen put it on a
different square dodge that check maybe
he can even move the black king
some options here he needs to avoid that
trade okay he retreats his bishop back
to cover um any potential checking
squares from the white queen dude
meanwhile exhaling there may be not so
happy i think due to mr trick just two
moves ago he could have brought his
queen back to the center of the board to
stop black's queen occupying this dream
square look at black's queen he was
shaking his head there wasn't he yeah i
mean and now and now past pawns need to
be pushed
actually has a clear run through two
seconds seven seconds as well not that
much time for dude he has to make a move
and uh panic it just feels like it's
starting to settle in yeah yeah i mean
it's all about centralizing queens and
magnus is the best player in the world
when it comes to centralizing queens
other players forget sometimes and now
white queen stuck behind its pawns it's
only protecting things black's queen
dominant on the dark squares black's
bishop dominant on the light squares i
mean you'd like two seconds for dude two
seconds
he's gonna move he made it with two
seconds left
he's quite a cool customer still isn't
he i mean like
he's not looking that cool actually
i'll say he's pretty cool but i mean
there is a limit oh
wow
wow i think it's a big mistake and look
at this black can continue pushing his
pawn because now if white's rook goes up
to capture one of the black pawns this
pawn will continue pushing down the
board black is almost about to make a
new queen how does he do how does he
always do it magnus i mean you always i
always think oh he's he's gonna struggle
to you know draw this one and then he
goes on to win yeah
maybe there's a few winning moves but
black can push his b pawn forward now
connect those two there we go the points
connect white can't take that pawn with
his own pawn because the black queen
would pounce and take the white rook in
the corner
these two black pawns are just going to
win the game white king coming trying to
ride to the rescue but it's not going to
be enough look at those two pawns if
white goes and captures a pawn now
there's going to be a check from the
black queen and white's rook is going to
drop yeah that one of those two black
pawns is going to cost white the rook
magnus is going to win henry seconds
five seconds and
he might lose some time here he might
just lose on time because he's lost
anyway i mean is that it is it over yeah
it is over it's over okay did he
actually lose on time or did he just
resign i think he just let his clock run
out because uh